l'ukraine pour le moment ne renonce pas
à ces verdonnaise des combats intenses
ont lieu dans le centre-ville à ce que
je sais il est difficile de savoir qui
contrôle la plupart de la ville un
moment donné mais aujourd'hui il y a eu
un communiqué du conseil national de
sécurité de défense ukrainien qui
semblait laisse ouverte la porte à
l'idée que l'ukraine pourrait se retirer
de severodonetsk et il disait ça en
soulignant que si jamais cela se fait ce
serait un retrait tactique et le but de
l'ukraine au final resterait la même de
récupérer tous les territoires du
donbass et du sud de l'ukraine qui sont
actuellement occupés par la russie